despite being one of the longest months
of the year october went by very very
quickly and we're already a little bit
into november so it's now time to do
some updates about what got done in in
october and what's coming up in november
both very busy months and a lot of
really cool announcements to to bring to
white to talk about
before i go into all that there's four
things that i want to sort of call
attention to
one is that the half hour hegel series
which we've been doing now since
february we finally reached one of the
very early milestones which is finishing
a section so the preface now is finally
done it took 31
31 lecture videos but we're going to be
moving into the introduction very soon
so that's a big bit of news another big
announcement
we brought out a new channel just a few
days ago on critical thinking logic and
argumentation if you remember back i've
been talking about
starting to do in a more organized way
more focused way bring out new channels
where it's just about one area of
philosophy or you know perhaps you know
one big classification i might do a
history of philosophy one which would of
course encompass
several different periods and a lot of
different thinkers but we got the first
one out which is on critical thinking
logic and argumentation and i'll talk
more about that
when i when i get to the months
stoic week is coming up this month of
november we're going to have a lot of
cool stuff lined up for that
and world philosophy day it's a unesco
united nations
event
that's also happening in november as
well as i said october was a very busy
month i had a few different talks going
on
in addition to the
glimpses into existence library series
talk that we've been doing this year at
the kingston library this month on
simone de beuvoir is a very fun session
i also went up to green mountain college
and
packed in both a talk and a faculty
development workshop
while i was up there beautiful place by
the way and they have some really
interesting programs there so the talk
was on
aristotle anger virtue and and vice and
you can see the video for it i'll link
to it here in the description and then i
also gave a faculty development seminar
and interestingly enough it was on
lecture capture which is using
video to capture what you're doing and
provide it to your students in this case
provide it to to viewers lifelong
learners anybody who's interested in
philosophy on the internet
so there was that and then another thing
that was very important for me was i
went to the american catholic
philosophical association
which is a it's a conference
that
you know they have their their own
association
which is pretty large um it might
actually be
the second largest philosophy
association in the united states after
the american philosophical association
which pretty much everyone's stuck
belonging to this is one that people
choose to belong to
and they focus on all sorts of things
all across the range
not everybody in it is a catholic
actually um certainly not everybody in
it is focused on you know traditional
catholic philosophers like thomas
aquinas or the guy who i worked on saint
anselm
and they have a lot of satellite
sessions and one of the satellite
sessions
at that that event was the institute for
saint anselm studies and i was invited
to come and give a talk
specifically about anselm's kurdish homo
mercy and justice it was part of a very
fun panel
i didn't get video of that but i did
create a podcast of that so i'll link to
that here as well
and it was really great to go back to
the acpa i hadn't been there since 2008
i i ran into a lot of old colleagues and
friends
made some new friends and uh talked with
quite a few people about
some really interesting topics this
great place if you're if you're
interested in aristotle or thomas
aquinas or um well even kierkegaard and
hegel
it's there's a lot of people there who
read these people and who really think
about them so that was a good one as
well
i did a lot of video work during october
as i said we we brought the half hour
hegel series
to its first close it's not the close of
the series which will happen about two
and a half years from now hopefully if
we stay on track
but we did finish the preface and so it
feels really good to get to the end of
of that we're getting ready to move
further with that but i'll talk about
that when i get to the november part um
shot a number of plato core concept
videos
and these were focused only mostly on on
the operatic dialogues like the amino
the ion the euthyphro
i did i did get one released on the fedo
on something that i think is really
important missology and and why we need
to avoid it
um
i did a 10 shorts video
and uh
answered some viewers questions i'll
probably do another one of those later
this month uh i shot a a video two
videos on kafka's metamorphosis i'm
finally getting back into
the existentialism series uh i need to
get more done on that
and of course as i mentioned we brought
out a brand new channel devoted to
critical thinking logic and
argumentation because those all kind of
fit together so that channel is going to
include those two disciplines of
critical thinking and logic but also
argument more broadly so you can expect
down the line to see things like uh
my doing a series on kind perlman's new
rhetoric
or
aristotle's categories and logical works
you know other mills methods things like
that things things that come along that
are in that vein maybe i'll do something
on clifford's ethics of belief because
that that often gets brought up in terms
of critical thinking
what's really cool about this is now
that i've got the new channel
i can
organize the content any way that i i
want to um
not really possible to do given how many
videos we've already got stuffed into
this channel and how many more i'm i'm
bringing out we're already past the 550
video mark
so
if i want to do
new things new projects along these
lines it really needs to be under the
aegis of a new channel
so what else
went on in october
developing course content still for some
online platforms ranging from you know
full four credit classes like a player
now i'm already starting to work on my
my marist online classes coming up later
this fall
and
um you know there's there's a few other
online platforms that i'm you could say
participating in in a very minor way but
getting ready to move into in a more
serious way
in in the coming months
i i did a lot of google help outs this
month that was that was kind of
fun to do
they can come out of
you know all different directions
ended up talking with people
about
things ranging from hegel's
phenomenology to ideas in plato or
nietzsche to rational choice theory and
how we should look at equations for that
sort of stuff
i'm slowly building the philosophical
counseling business there's quite a few
moving parts to that
i've been doing more blogging not not as
much as i'd like yet but i'm getting
more consistent with the blog entries
and staying on top of that and i did get
some some academic writing done and that
felt very good um there's some you know
a lot of projects that i've got going a
lot of old orphaned papers that i need
to start sending out for publication
um
so yeah there's there's all of that i
also um contributed some some sound
files for the punk rock philosopher's
show if you if you don't know what that
is um it's a friend and colleague of
mine who does something rather unique he
takes philosophy discussions
and mixes in
um
mixes in
music and it can be all over the map
he's got some pretty wide tastes
uh and some of his own discussions about
things and some of the sound files
that i i provide him with he's been
focusing a lot on on plato and trying to
come up with connections between plato
not not genetic connections but sort of
similarity connections plato and eastern
philosophy so
um you know
kind of an innovative
idea to to do that sort of thing
and i started doing one other thing that
was new this month i started loading up
podcasts and i've been storing them in
archive.org
in part because i
just not quite sure where i want to go
with them
and i need to have a home for them and
that makes them public domain so that
that's kind of cool
but i've also been um compiling them in
a list in in my main blog orexis dna tk
if you go to rexa studio etk and you
want to see the podcast there's a button
there you just click on it
they come down and you can see them so
far i think i have eight or nine in
there but um we're looking at eventually
um
you know having hundreds of podcasts and
this is all just at this point old
material talks that i've given at
various places we're going to take the
glimpses of existence turn them into
podcasts turn some of the class stuff
into podcasts
but eventually down the line i'm going
to start doing some some new series that
are just podcast stuff but i'll tell you
more about that when that happens
november is lined up to be an
extraordinarily busy month probably the
busiest that we've ever had so i'm kind
of glad that we have relatively light
stuff on the calendar for december at
this point
i have talks lined up
pretty much every single week during the
month some some doubling up
on the sixth we have uh theology matters
which is an internet radio show uh you
can listen live or you can hear a
podcast of it they're having me on to
talk about saint augustine and his views
on divine existence and the divine
nature
i'll mostly be talking about stuff
coming out of his on the free choice of
the will but some stuff from the
confessions don't some stuff perhaps
from city god or on christian doctrine
the ninth at the rock tavern unitarian
universalist church i will be giving a
sermon
on ancient christian attitudes towards
anger so that's a bit of a different
genre but it's it's kind of fun to
branch out
and uh i've been wanting to try this for
for a while
um
on the 16th you had a different genre
i'll be on radio woodstock round table
in the morning and
i'm not quite sure yet what we're
talking about but i'm hoping to steer
the conversation to the stuff that's
coming up later that month
the 20th is world philosophy day it's a
unesco holiday and they give you pretty
broad latitude about how you want to
celebrate it so what i'm doing
is i've actually got lined up a
friend and colleague of mine leandro
lima who is um by by uh profession he's
he's a programmer but he's been working
for
several years now on a project that i've
been i've been helping him out with as
you know uh president of reason io
in terms of critical thinking
and
it's called truth score it's really you
know it it's it's a great platform
because what it allows you to do is to
model argument and allow people to build
out
cases for things and then to weigh in on
whether they think it's a good argument
or a bad argument
down to the very
premises and conclusions of them
so
this has a lot of potential for raising
the bar
when it comes to public discourse
uh in terms of of debate critical
thinking
you know all sorts of things
so that's going to be an interesting
conversation if you can join us
uh it'll be bro it'll be broadcast live
you know using uh google hangouts on air
we'll also have a video of it that
you'll be able to to watch afterwards
you can actually use the q a app to go
and put questions in that you want us to
answer comments
ahead of time and we'll try to get to
all of them if we can i think i've got
him down for an hour but i might try to
squeeze an hour and a half out of them
then
the 11th glimpses of existence
lecture at the historic kingston library
this one is going to be on albert camus
a really important existentialist
thinker i'm going to try to cover a lot
of ground i'm going to talk about the
early works like the
mythic symphysis and the stranger
and go into the later things
like
the plague
and the fall and the rebel
and talk about the differences between
these
uh
call out some of camus you know
main ideas usually we get a really great
crowd and some great discussions so if
you can't physically be there you can
you can at least watch the video we post
the videos for all these glimpses of
existence
sessions
that'll be the 11th we're almost near
the end of the year
we're talking with the library about
what what series we might do next year
so that's something kind of cool coming
up and then it's something really big
and i haven't done anything with this in
the past
but i've decided i want to jump into
this this year
uh the 24th through the 30th
is stoic week
and what do you do during stoic week
while you talk about stoicism and
there's there's lots and lots of room
for different kinds of events we sent
out queries uh
last couple weeks to some of the local
institutions even some of the local high
schools to see if people are interested
and we got a few nibbles
we'll see later in the month whether
whether we consolidate these things or
not at the very least myself i am going
to have
a dr sather philosophy forum where i'm
going to field questions about
stoicism and we'll talk you know about
important stoic thinkers what effects
they've had all sorts of things like
that i'll probably do that as a kickoff
thing on the 24th
i'm going to release videos each day
of that that week
devoted specifically to stoicism so
we're looking at guys like epictetus
seneca cicero i'm really a big fan of
cicero i know somebody's gonna say
wasn't you know technically a stoic but
he he tells us a lot about stoicism and
he was influenced by them so marcus
aurelius um
we'll do quite a bit on them
uh even on thanksgiving american
thanksgiving i'll probably do something
on stoicism and gratitude at that point
might do some discussion about stoicism
and
it's it's you know modern forms like
cognitive behavior therapy which is
influenced by stoicism but in any case
that's that's coming up
might do some blogging about that as
well
so um
what do we got going on as far as videos
um we're going to start new hegel videos
so we finished with the preface
conveniently by the end of october and
now we're going to go into hegel's
introduction you might say why does he
have an introduction after the preface
well when you go into the introduction
you'll see it's much more
straightforward and easier to understand
than the prefaces which seems to be like
all over the map
that one won't take quite as long
because there are only 17 paragraphs
to it as opposed to 72 as there were in
the preface so i'm thinking
if we really
you know
make good progress we could have it
finished up by the end of the month if
not probably by mid-december
so that's the half hour hegel videos
in the existentialism series i i
committed to shooting a lot more kafka
i've got the trial to go through
i decided that in addition to those two
i also want to shoot videos
on um the letter to his father
inside the penal colony
uh the judgment and
his discussions of parables so that's a
lot of videos to come up this month if i
if i do get through all of those and i
still have the energy to do it i i could
consider shooting stuff on simone de
beauvoir because we need to get some of
her stuff into the series as well but i
think that's a lot of existentialism
videos i'm going to shoot some more
play-doh videos more core concept videos
got some fado material to go through
but then i also want to start doing some
on
one of the greatest works of plato the
symposium
as i mentioned earlier we have a whole
new channel that's out this critical
thinking channel
and i've already got four videos
uploaded in the first playlist the first
playlist is about the fallacies i want
to start with something that's pretty
straightforward something that people
can
start using right away and then i'm
going to start adding more things in
like you know
deductive and inductive and abductive
arguments and how to you know diagram
arguments why that's a useful thing to
do and
how to evaluate information sources and
and then we'll start getting into more
and more uh technical things probably
having to do with logic or rhetoric
but that's that's down the line for this
month we're going to concentrate on
churning out these fallacy videos i want
to create a robust
playlist that people can use
in part because i think we're probably
getting close to the time of the
semester
when
there's lots and lots of critical
thinking classes going on and students
are going to be kind of panicking a
little bit about you know how do i get
keep all these fallacies straight in my
head and what are they because they'll
be taking tests on them so this will be
a really great resource for that and and
we have you know we've already got four
of those fallacy videos shot we've
probably got about another 50 or so to
produce in that series so and that's not
even including in is you know ones that
are just devoted to examples in each of
those videos the ones that i've i'm
uploading now i give three examples i'm
also going to create some that are just
chock full of examples uh so that people
can use those
um
writing projects that's another thing
that that november is supposed to be
focused on
uh i have a few papers on aristotle and
anselm and even if if i can get to it
i've got a hobbes paper too
that have been sitting there for a while
some of them i presented at conferences
before some of them um i just you know
started writing and never completely
brought to a
satisfactory totally polished finish
but they need to find homes so i need to
get them in in
good enough shape to get start getting
sent out to journals
and
i've got you know quite a few of those
one on aristotle and pro-iracis
uh anselm on marriage uh the one that i
just presented recently about anselm and
curtis homo and justice mercy all those
sort of things need to start getting
sent out
i'm still working on the aristotle book
projects i'm currently developing you
know a prospectus for a book on
aristotle leadership uh the aristotle
and anger stuff i'm working on chapters
with that right now and in addition to
those uh i've got a end of november
deadline for a different writing project
a textbook and i need to get the
proposal and the sample chapter for that
finished i'm in you know communication
with a press that that wants
they want me to write for them but they
also they want me to jump through a lot
of hoops as they always do
um what else have we got going on in
november um i'm going to be continuing
vlogging so i should i should run
through the list of my my blogs my main
blog is a rexus dia no etiquette that's
sort of your one-stop shop
for
you know links to all the other things
that i'm doing
tells you about
you know
there's it links you to the video
courses to the podcasts uh keeps you
updated about what's going on
um with with other projects that i i'm
i'm involved in
uh
virtue ethics digest i'm i'm i didn't
get that much done just one post for
that last month but i've got a few ideas
lined up for this month sandler
existentialism updates that one's moving
along full steam so i'm just going to
keep that going
heavy metal philosopher haven't written
in that for a while but we just saw two
uh big shows
over the last uh month and a half so i
probably need to do some writing about
that i've got some other ideas i want to
start putting down not on paper but
electronically
and what am i leaving out the half hour
hegel blog
mostly that's posting like hey we got
this video up we got this video up but
every once in a while if i have some
rumination about hegel
i'll put that down and there's been a
really interesting development having to
do with the half hour hegel videos
and the series
and a social media platform that picked
up on it i'm not going to tell you about
it here you got to go to the blog
and check it out if you want to know
what it is but i'll just say it's it's
pretty cool and i'll be releasing that i
finally wrote the blog entry for that
i'll be releasing that later this week
um still collaborating with the punk
rock philosopher whose shows uh
come out on wednesdays now
you can listen to them live or you can
you can download them it's you know even
if you just listen to it as background
music he's got some some pretty
interesting musical tastes and you know
there's a little bit of philosophy mixed
in with that as well so you can bone up
on your on your plato
that's everything that's coming up for
november so that that's quite a bit uh
we'll see how we do with getting all of
this this done
certainly you can expect to see a lot of
new video content uh if you can make it
to any of my talks
come on in and introduce yourself and
i'll be happy to to chat with you about
that um
and
not much you can do in terms of the
writing projects that stuff i have to
work on myself but if you uh you know if
you enjoy this channel
come on over to the critical thinking
channel if you're into that sort of
thing and see if you want to subscribe
to that as well
um great way to stay updated about all
the new material that we'll be adding
there otherwise have a great uh month of
november join us for uh
the uh
world philosophy day event and during
stoic week we want to try to get a lot
of participation in those because uh i
think those are really great for
philosophy to actually have some things
on the calendar otherwise have a great
month